let's get back to what's going down this
Sunday right here the Golden Globes
comedy legend Carol Burnett is being
recognized with the show's inaugural
Carol Burnett award
it's the globe's top honor for
achievement and television and et has
been lucky enough to be with her many
times over the years and we've got the
Tarzan yells to prove it
that would be my legacy she could do the
Tarzan yell the Tarzan yell is iconic
but when the Carol Burnett show
premiered in 1967 its namesake star was
breaking down barriers' as the first
woman ever to host her own variety
sketch show I could do a variety show
but the network didn't want me to do
what they said it's a man's game I just
really didn't I'm a clown I wanted to do
sketches and sing a song or two
this trailblazer has done it all over a
career that spans seven decades and et's
been with her for a lot of it I never
went into this to be famous I wanted to
just work so television was the farthest
thing from my mind it wasn't anything
that I thought I would do you know why
not do it but the same I never thought
about it but as the TV legend prepares
for Sunday's honor there's one other
tribute Carol's ready for a biopic about
her life and she's already got a cast oh
it's obvious Angelina Jolie I mean who
else I could see Angelina doing that
ours an call but in real life who should
play Carol Amy Adams how about that or
isla Fisher either one
[Music]